let's talk about Ashley Judd because
perhaps by the time we get this out she
may have announced that she's running
for Congress in Kentucky where she lived
as a child for part of it she went to
University of Kentucky and she'd be
running for the seat that now Mitch
McConnell who's one of those powerful
congressmen we have and who's also part
human part turtle
he is so she's he's not happy about that
and the ads even though she hasn't
declared have already started coming out
let's take a look at this one you know
what this country really needs an
independent voice for Obama I am
committed to President Obama and Vice
President Biden I think he's a brilliant
man he is now able to flower more as the
president I knew he could be a leader
who knows how to follow someone who will
never forget where she came from and it
just clicked Tennessee is home and it
just clicked Kentucky is home someone
who knows what's good for us someone who
shares our values
someone from out of state who
understands us
no police I don't know a lot of
hillbillies of golf hillbillies
Hillbillies hillbillies her own
grandmother says she's a Hollywood
liberal but isn't that what we need
Ashley Judd and Obama following radical
Hollywood liberal who's right at home
here in Tennessee in Kentucky
her whole family thinks she's a
Hollywood liberal this is her
grandmother she is not gonna get a
Christmas present this year I'm pretty
sure about that all right so that ad now
again Ashley Judd has not even announced
that she's running that ad was brought
to you by the fine folks over at
Crossroads for America which is Karl
Rove super PAC which I'm pretty sure
lost every election that they got
involved in this past November Adam yes
what do you think about this Kenna Kenna
Hollywood elitist eat a human turtle I
think that any party that was in the
movie Tooth Fairy president construe as
a Hollywood elitist I think you have to
like I mean her last good movie was uh
was it kiss the girls I mean that was 15
years ago so you make her star quality
isn't even high enough to I don't think
she's a Hollywood elitist I think she
should but I think that she should be
the coach of Kentucky because she's been
at every game I don't really think that
she's because she could win maybe I
don't think so I mean based on I don't
think she could win I mean but it she's
pretty hot does he do I think do you
think that it takes these of course do
you think that it takes these
high-profile whether they're not a
listers or whether they are a-listers
happen do you think it takes these
high-profile people to now run because a
regular person really can't even run for
office anymore just because of
connections and money and everything
else well a regular person can run
they're just very unlikely to win
especially at the Senate level I mean
right now the barriers to entry for a
regular person you know you have to have
like a ten thousand dollar filing fee
I'm not sure what it is for Kentucky but
usually in most states at several
thousand dollars and you have to have a
whole apparatus and a petition that
shows you have support you have to
basically be able to prove that you can
pay for the TV commercials so in that
respect Ashley Judd you know who is a
very intelligent woman it has a great
resume outside of her acting career as
well I think she would be able to for it
to afford it you don't you may not
this but she was actually UN I think is
an ambassador for one of the programs
and I'm sorry I can't remember right now
but I love the fact that she's even
talking about this because you could
tell how much the GOP is freaked out
about it well clearly because this ad is
actually about a month old and still as
we tape this right now she hasn't even
officially jumped in it looks like it
could happen any moment and they're
already running ads against her so hey
John where do you honey she beat he went
back she went back to her husband she
was able to take down her husband in
double jeopardy anyone who can do that
can take down Mitch McConnell in the
serious part I will say she I think she
is a credible candidate I think she
would be incredibly credible candidate
only because we've seen real people win
big offices Barack Obama being a great
example of this when he won the US
Senate in Illinois before he gave that
speech he was just a regular state
representative he was a common man who
put was put into circumstances a sex
scandal not his but another candidate
sex scandal that got him to that seat so
he was a regular person that got there
albeit because of circumstances so it is
possible for a regular person to be even
be elected president I think but I I do
think that she we've seen candidates
crazy candidates get elected Jesse
Ventura I'm not comparing her Jesse
Ventura but there's a great example of
somebody who's kind of out there yeah in
a state in a country now that has Barack
Obama as president that has kind of were
leaning in a unique direction yeah I
think she could easily sneak in there
what also has the name recognition I
mean in Kentucky the judge family the
judges are very popular and have been
for four decades now so I think she's
got the name recognition and it would be
awesome I think to see her run against
Mitch McConnell even if she didn't have
a snowball's chance in hell because it
would give a chance for the GOP to show
just how anti-woman they still are in
the campaign that they would run against
her absolutely so how important is it to
get rid of this old guard you know we're
talking about McCain earlier but McCain
and Lindsey Graham who now may have an
openly gay guy running against him in
the primary which i think is fantastic
how important is it to get rid of these
old guys and they're they're not gonna
go away quietly right I don't know I
like Ashley Judd I think she's very Pro
woman and does a lot
like great charity she seems like a very
educated I would vote for her if I lived
in Kentucky I'm all about term limits
for even senators senators and con think
there should be term limits I'm I
understand that sometimes seniority in
the Senate in res run on seniority but I
think having someone in there for 40
years just creates this establishment
that then doesn't get anything done it
create create situations like well Rand
Paul wasn't part of that ramp or
anything even for the president I think
that it a couple guys doing a good job
keep him there I might like a Bill
Clinton what a fact you stayed in you
know and then George Bush had I mean
imagine I mean there might not guessing
you're not for term limit I am NOT for
term limits yeah there's some studies
that show that when you put them in
place in states that they actually
increase the power of party bosses
because that means that people have to
then move around you know they're like
oh I'm term limited out of this so that
means that the party boss then has more
power over who does get put up into
these primary elections and then on to
what happens in in in the actual office
because people don't have that
institutional memory they don't remember
what happened for and they take some
that much longer to learn the job before
they're actually effective in it so it's
an interesting I think the problem that
you're talking about is money in
politics you know that if we didn't have
the the corruption of money throughout
the campaigns and the lobbying when
you're already when you do get to
elected office that that's where the
issues actually lie in that you know
term limits wouldn't necessarily save
that that's why I'm actually only half
kidding when I say this but I think
politicians should only be allowed to
run once because then they wouldn't
spend the second half of the first time
looking forward to the second abling I
lost like every election before I became
president I can't argue against Lincoln
that would be
bonobos comm is the official outfitter
of the Reuben report get this shirt used
code TRR t0f analyst calm